a landmark
liftoff launching a new era of space
exploration
and resilience rises not even gravity
contains humanity when we explore
as one for all
and nasa's return to routine missions
thanks to an astronomical outsourcing
deal
spacex is a private company contracted
to fly astronauts to
and from the international space station
and that's where this rocket is heading
and you see that stage separation has
confirmed
there goes that mvac engine
everybody is so fired up they're so
excited about this mission
but we're not done yet we need to keep
going that spacecraft's out there with
those four precious crew members on them
and we're going to get them to safely to
the international space station tomorrow
right
and we've got shutdown of the second
stage engine on time
the crew three american and one japanese
will spend six months on board
orbiting the earth among them commander
victor glover
soon to become the first black crew
member of the international space
station
and separation confirmed
this is a great day for the united
states of america and a great day for
japan
and we look forward to many more years
of a great partnership
not just in low earth orbit but all the
way to the moon the crew have named
their capsule resilience
reflecting the hardships of the global
pandemic
now far below them nasa retired its
shuttles in 2011
and had relied on the russians for rides
that's why
this mission is a giant leap for both
the future
of nasa and commercial space travel
laura bundock sky news